accident mortel pour didier pironi
bernard giraud et jean claude guinard
cela s'est passé cet après midi au large
de l'île de wight menace de néo nazis à
quelques jour de l'inhumation de rudolph
hess la police allemande sur les dents
stats de deuxième avec girard aux une
journée supplémentaire de détention pour
marcel carton
marcel fontaine jean paul kauffmann jean
louis normandin d'antenne 2 et roger
auque les otages français au liban n'ont
toujours pas été libérés
bonsoir ruban noir sur le sport il
vivait à 200 à l'heure c'était sa
passion et sa passion l'a tué didier
pironi a trouvé la mort en compagnie de
bernard giroux et de jean claude guinard
au large de l'île de wight au moment de
l'accident
didier pironi était aux commandes d'un
off shore ce monstre mécanique en forme
de cigare dont il s'était juré de
devenir le meilleur pilote
les aubes sort ce sont les formule 1 de
la mer cet après midi pendant une course
du championnat du monde à plus de 160 km
heure le bateau de pironi s'est envolé
et retourner didier pironi avait failli
devenir champion du monde de formule 1
en 82 mais il y avait eu l'accident
d'hockenheim patrick n'a nous allons
recevoir voir l'image de didier pironi
dans tout ce qu'il a entrepris celle
d'un gagneur autre image de pironi en f1
son terrible accident le 8 août 82 aux
essais du grand prix d'allemagne après
ses victoires aux pays bas et à san
marin il était en tête du championnat du
monde est en passe de devenir le premier
français champion du monde de formule 1
trois ans et demi de calvaire 40
interventions chirurgicales pour
récupérer l'usagé de sa jambe droite
une volonté opiniâtre qui force
l'admiration de tous une volonté destiné
à revenir au premier plan pour retrouver
un volant le refus de
de vouloir être handicapé et
psychologique il ya de plus important
bon pour pour le genre de choses que
j'ai eu quelques essais confidentielle
puisse à nouveau les gestes rituels
quatre ans presque jour pour jour après
son accident d'abord sur une ag s puis
surtout sur une ligier qui renie revient
avec des performances ce jour-là il
tourne à une seconde de rené arnoux
il est prêt à recourir il ne lui manque
un volant si je fais de la formule 1 je
t'ai déjà dit cent cinquante fois mais
je le redis encore parce que c'est
vraiment mon but c'est pour être
champion du monde donc je ne referai pas
de la formule 1 dans de mauvaises
conditions
pas de volant de f1 pour pironi en 87
l'occasion pour didier d'assouvir sa
deuxième passion le off shore je suis
heureux dans la mesure où je rêve encore
beaucoup à des choses que je veux
réaliser ou des choses que je rêve
d'avoir manqué un peu ça le secret du
bonheur c'est pas tout près serré mais
c'est de rêver d'avoir plus à 35 ans
didier pironi avec le même enthousiasme
qu'à ses débuts en automobile se lancer
dans un nouveau défi
le titre mondial avec son bateau le
colibri il en avait pris le chemin en
signant sa première victoire la semaine
dernière en norvège
un pari qu'il avait entamée avec ses
amis jean claude besnard et bernard
giroux deux autres fous de formule 1
disparu aujourd'hui avec lui au large de
l'île de wight donc des réactions gérard
holtz
oui un télégramme de jacques chirac
adressé aux familles des trois victimes
je m'associe ou au deuil du monde
sportif a dit le premier ministre
je m'incline devant la douleur des
proches de ces hommes qui ont vécu leur
passion sportive jusqu'au bout et puis
un télégramme de christian berger l'un
qui parle de l' enthousiasme de ces
trois sportifs et de leur goût pour le
défi avec didier pironi se trouve et je
voulais dit bernard giroux et jean
claude guénin bernard giroud c'est notre
confrère spécialisé dans les sports
mécaniques cd en seulement notre
confrère gérard holtz mais c'était aussi
votre ami oui bernard stamm est éteint
un gars bien c'était un vrai
professionnel dans son métier
journaliste reporter à tf1
et en plus il savait avoir le goût du
risque
il le disait lui-même la peur ne me fait
pas peur
et depuis quelques mois il avait donc
monté cette écurie de hors-bord de
course les fameux offshore avec didier
pironi et avec jean claude guénin et un
mot les liait tous les trois c'était le
mot passion passion pour didier pironi
surdoué de la formule 1 intelligent
lucide qui après son terrible accident
de conan s'était reconverti donc dans la
course offshore avec tailleur une
première victoire la semaine dernière en
norvège passion pour jean claude liénard
grand spécialiste des sports mécaniques
que l'on voit ici qui était un ami
d'enfance de didier pironi qui c'était
qu'il y avait eu des responsabilités
chez ligier et passion aussi pour
bernard giroux notre ami notre confrère
qui lui avait permis entre autres de
gagner deux fois le paris dakar avec
maître jean 80 et avec vatanen en 87 3
sportif emportés par leur passion
bonsoir tout à l'heure pour le reste de
l'actualité sportive genre veillée
d'armes pour veillée funèbre en
allemagne une inquiétante garde noire
s'est donné rendez-vous dans le petit
village de wunsiedel bourgade de bavière
ou rudolph hess sera enterré mercredi
prochain 88 néo-nazis ont déjà été
arrêtées et les abords du cimetière
transformé par la police en camp
retranché
les manifestations sont interdites ainsi
que l'hymne nazi pour le jour des
funérailles
dernier soubresaut de la bête immonde
vous premier frisson de nostalgiques du
iiième reich en culottes courtes
jérôme bonnet trois jours avant
l'enterrement ils sont déjà là nous
arrivons lentement mais déterminée
affirmé leurs banderoles une centaine
aujourd'hui il pourrait être plusieurs
milliers mercredi bravant l'interdiction
de manifester qu'ils n'aient des
néonazis venus d'un peu partout
malgré les contrôles sur les routes
bavaroise pour rendre hommage à leur
héros pourtant du fond de la prison de
spandau rudolph hess avait confié à
l'aumônier à français le pasteur charles
gamble puis tenez les manifestants néo
nazis pour des fous ou des provocateurs
ils s'amusent avec une époque révolue
disent-ils ils me rendent aucun service
les préparatifs pour la destruction de
cette prison dont il était le seul
détenu ont commencé on veut effacer un
symbole mais cela suffira-t-il
le maire de venise elle craque son
cimetière ne devienne le lieu de
pèlerinage de ceux qui n'ont rien appris
de l'histoire
pourtant elle est bien là dans ce
cimetière l'histoire puisque à quelques
mètres du caveau de la famille f1 autres
caves opportune stèle avec l'inscription
à la mémoire des victimes du fascisme
cérémonie du souvenir aujourd'hui à la
cascade du bois de boulogne là le 16
août 1944 35 jeunes gens des résistants
étaient massacrés par la gestapo jeunes
communistes ou jeunes chrétiens
appartement appartenant aux forces
françaises de l'intérieur ou forant
tireurs partisans il était chargé de
récupérer des armes destinées à la
résistance de jours plus tard paris a
été libérée par la 2e db du général
leclerc
et c'est justement mardi prochain que
paris fêtera le 43ème anniversaire de sa
libération
on n'aime pas les arabes on connaît la
rengaine mais la rengaine a une fois de
plus fait des victimes un jeune
maghrébin passé à tabac par trois hommes
qui l'avaient pris en auto-stop
les trois hommes l'ont frappé à coups de
clé à molette lui en coupé une phalange
avant de le jeter dans un fossé
ce soir sos racisme a décidé d'apporter
toute son aide matérielle et juridique à
la victime nouvelle calédonie des
ricochets sur le caillou et quelques
remous politiques autour au lendemain de
la longue marche interrompue du fln ks
six militants indépendantistes inculpé
deux gendarmes blessés et ses
commentaires pour jus de lionel jospin
en voyant ces images d'hommes et de
femmes paisiblement assis et matraqué
sur ordres de monsieur pons
j'ai eu honte pour ceux qui nous
gouvernent réponse de l'intéressé la
longue marche du fln ks est un échec
nous ne laisserons pas dégénérer la
situation fin de citation
deux camps d'un côté les caldoches de
l'autre les kanaks plus on s'approche de
l'échéance du 13 septembre prochain date
du référendum d'autodétermination
le fossé se creuse de plus en plus entre
les communautés en nouvelle calédonie et
quand par hasard ou par conviction
les néo calédoniens franchi cette
frontière ils passent parfois aux yeux
de leur communauté d'origine pour des
moutons noirs
c'est cette histoire que nous raconte
nos envoyés spéciaux
rachid arhab et philippe péters
tio où l'image de la crise néo
calédonienne ce pont en effet symboliser
le fossé qui se creusait entre kanaks et
caldoches pendant les événements de 84
la ville était coupée du reste du pays
aujourd'hui le travail a repris dans les
mines de nickel richesses du territoire
une richesse qui diminue à cause de la
concurrence d'autres minerais mais
surtout à cause de la crise politique
toujours sous terraines ici les
affrontements d'il ya trois ans ont
effectivement laissé des traces et des
traces pas seulement dans le coeur des
kanaks quelques caldoches des blancs
donc ont épousé les thèses
indépendantistes
madame moulédous calédonienne de trois
générations le paye aujourd'hui son
commerce a été incendié sa famille
rejeté par les caldoches loyalistes
madame moulédous a enregistré les
menaces les âges dure qu'elle a entendu
un peu comme le testament d'une
caldoches qui ne comprend pas ce qui
s'est passé depuis son enfance en
nouvelle-calédonie chalet 12 ans ont
joué avec les filets des écoles c'était
que des indigènes ont mangé avec le ter
auch avec les chefs
entendez ça normal qu'elle n'était pas
du tout dépaysé d'être parmi les
indigènes
comment vous expliquez les réactions de
la majorité des européens ici est bien
certain c'est par fierté
d'autres c'est par bêtise et puis
d'autres séparés par intérêt est-ce
qu'ils estiment que vous êtes un traître
non non je pense pas qu'ils m'appellent
traite je pense pas que c'est ça non
pour eux je suis rien du tout vu que je
suis du côté des kanaks
seuls les kanaks viennent pas encore ma
petite maison de madame moulédous une
dame de 58 ans qui attend le retour de
ses deux fils emprisonné pour avoir
lancé des cailloux sur jacques lafleur
le député rpcr chez les moulédous en et
indépendantistes de mère en fils aux
petits enfants seront points
mais certains acquis
dès que naquit plan alors qu'elles
avaient scellé tanaka golden et gardez
vous
toute cette famille prend le risque de
faire partie un jour d'une minorité
celle des blancs qui resterait en
nouvelle calédonie après une éventuelle
indépendance tout chantage sur les
otages et abominable c'est ce qu'a
déclaré jean bernard et bon cet après
midi interrogé par nos confrères de fr3
rmc le ministre des affaires étrangères
a ajouté toujours à propos de l' affaire
des otages le gouvernement français
souhaite avoir des interlocuteurs
crédibles mais nos confrères ont aussi
voulu en savoir plus sur la situation
des diplomates français retenus à
l'ambassade de téhéran
réponse du ministre madame tories et son
bébé âgé de deux mois vont quitter
incessamment ce pays
écoutez le en ce qui concerne nos
diplomates qui sonde à terre d'abord je
rappelle qu'ils sont très peu nombreux
spas il ya onze personnes ayant un
statut diplomatique
parmi ces 11 personnes il ya la femme
d'un des consuls et son bébé qui est né
laborde presque au moment des événements
et nous venons d'avoir la réponse
officielle iranienne selon laquelle elle
pourra rentrer incessamment en france ça
c'est un point la cli officiellement ce
sera le seul qui pourra parti m pour le
moment nous avons isolé son cas parce
que c'est une femme avec un bébé et nous
considérons sur le plan humanitaire
elle a une certaine priorité d'autant
plus que nous avons laissé partir
énormément des bouses et de famille
d'iraniens qui étaient retenus en france
mystère toujours à propos de la
disparition de cet hélicoptère dans le
golfe dont je vous parlais dans le
journal de 13 heures d'après l'iran cinq
journalistes auraient pays danse péri
dans cet accident
information démentie par le pentagone ce
soir l'agencé de presse iranienne irna
dément l'information sur laquelle la
marine iranienne aurait repêcher les
cinq corps je ferai tout mon possible
pour contribuer à la libération de terry
wayne
c'est ce qu'a déclaré le colonel kadhafi
en recevant le docteur les six
représentants de l'église anglicane
le colonel kadhafi qui au cours de cet
entretien devait avoir en tête cette
information divulguée par les tchadiens
un mig-23 et un hélicoptère de combat
ont été abattus hier au dessus de house
ou des résultats qui semblent confirmer
que l'armée tchadienne a trouvé un
système de défense anti-aérien efficace
pour faire face aux contre offensive des
troupes libyennes amateurs à vos
chéquiers une drôle de machine venue
d'ailleurs va débarquer c'est une
japonaise pour ne rien vous cacher elle
doit être présenté à la presse
internationale dans les jours qui
viennent signalement quatre roues
directrices quatre roues directrices oui
performance c'est la surprise
alors attachez vos ceintures et où les
bolides c'est patrick boitet qui conduit
même pour les très bons conducteurs
il ya des virages qui porte sur les murs
avec la nouvelle voiture quatre roues
directrices plus de problème de braquage
regardez ça passe tout seul à grande
vitesse la moindre shipcom peut-être
difficile voire dangereuse à négocier
avec une voiture traditionnelle avec la
honda 4 euros directrice la voiture à
une maniabilité bien supérieur elle ne
les vit pratiquement pas ça une voiture
comporte quatre roues et sur les
voitures traditionnelles et roues
arrière sont inactives
nous avons pensé que si nous pouvions
les utiliser de manière plus efficace
la voiture serait plus facile à conduire
avec le système monde à une faible
impulsion au volant un prime aux roues
arrière un sens de direction dans le
même sens que les roues avant
en revanche un fort braquage commandes
aux roues arrière une direction opposée
à celle des roues avant
l'angle de rotation du volant détermine
donc le sens des directions des roues
arrière
comme sur un véhicule conventionnel le
système comporte un boîtier de direction
avant par pignon et crémaillère assurant
la commande du train avant mais ici le
mouvement de direction et relayé par un
arbre centrale commandant aussi un
boîtier de direction arrière la commande
s'effectue en fonction de l'angle du
braquage du volant
tout le monde pour enrouler comme les
professionnels
une attention avec de telles voitures il
ne faudrait pas que certains chauffeurs
oublient les règles élémentaires de la
conduite la honda 4 roues directrices
symbolise bien la nouvelle stratégie des
constructeurs nippons
ils veulent désormais fabriquer les
voitures plus inventives et de meilleure
qualité
mazda annonce qu'il va commercialiser un
modèle avec un système entièrement
électronique
dans les deux cas le surcoût dans
l'achat dû véhicule devrait varier entre
5000 et 10000 francs 4 morts en moyenne
par jour le mal de l'altitude n'est pas
forcément ceux que l'on croit
bardé de l'idée selon laquelle la
montagne serait à la portée de tous de
plus en plus d' imprudence se lance à
l'assaut des cimes résultat beaucoup de
cases bien sûr et des sauveteurs sur la
brèche contraints de travailler sans
cesse au bord de la rupture pour
répondre aux nombreux appels de détresse
reportage patrice volet philippe lalaye
ils ont suivi pour nous le peloton de
gendarmerie de haute montagne
beau temps sur le massif du mont-blanc
jour de sortie pour les alpinistes et
pourtant la montagne leur réserve bien
des surprises sur la mer de glace une
corde et vient de dévisser l'un des
hommes est coincé au fond d'une crevasse
la seule solution attendre les secours
intervention du peloton de gendarmerie
de chamonix comme 330 fois déjà cette
année en 87 de plus en plus de monde en
haute montagne
de plus en plus d'accidents aussi ça
fait longtemps tiré dans le trou fait
vivement pris aux belges du stade sous
lequel tous les cas ce qu'a ta jambe
cassée branchement on arrive à pour les
secours chamonix dispose de quarante
gendarmes spécialisés tous guide de
montagne
la plupart skieurs confirmés je suis dit
m verticale victimes vous pouvez
continuer la descente
chaque année le pghm améliore son
matériel d'intervention
par exemple le marteau à glace on sorte
de marteau piqueur pour dégager les
victimes coincées au fond des crevasses
par des blocs de glace
mise en place d'une gouttière pour
soutenir la jambe cassée l'opération la
plus délicate
reste ensuite à évacuer le blessé le
plus vite possible vers la vallée en
haute montagne
le froid est le principal ennemi du
corps humain les accidents les plus
graves et les plus fréquents sont ce qui
se passe sur des parois glacière ou ses
shows des courses enneigée il faut quand
même reconnaître que alpinistes dans
leur majorité sont des gens responsables
et j'incrimine ray plutôt un manque de
connaissance du milieu de la haute
montagne et des facteurs que tout
alpinistes doit prendre en considération
avant d'entreprendre une course de
grande ampleur il s'agit là de prévoir
les conditions météorologiques sont
propres au niveau physique et technique
et être sûr d'avoir un matériel adéquat
cette année dans le massif du mont-blanc
la montagne a déjà frappé 37 fois les
gendarmes ont ramené deux cent trente
sept blessés dans la vallée
un bilan plus lourd que l'an dernier la
montagne ne pardonne pas l'inexpérience
de la montagne aux sports la voix est
balisé donc la transition facile pour
passer la stat de deuxième avec gérard
holtz notre guide de ce soir est d'abord
du canoë kayak
oui avec une victoire pour les français
aux championnats du monde d'okara et
boucherie en k2 en gagner au championnat
du monde du x bourle 10000 mètres donc
médaille d'or moto grand prix
tchécoslovaquie sur le circuit de brno
wayne gardner a gagné le grand prix des
cinq centimètres cubes
l'allemand manga gagner les deux cent
cinquante centimètres cubes dominique
sarron et second en 125 victoire de
l'italien fao sto gresini et d'ailleurs
il est devenu champion du monde 1987 des
125 natation en record du monde à
strasbourg aujourd'hui c'était cet après
midi en direct sur antenne 2 le hongrois
tamas darniche a battu deux records du
monde du 200 m 4 nages en 2000
8 e et 56 centièmes l'ancien record
appartenait au canadien alex baumann en
deux une 42 centièmes et puis du bronze
pour les françaises avec le water polo
oui c'est tout à fait surprenant elle
n'était pas venu pour gagner ni même une
médaille même le tournoi et pourtant
elle termine à la troisième place avec
une médaille de bronze pour les équipes
de france de water-polo qui est un
véritable exploit en fait derrière
médaille de bronze donc derrière les
pays bas et la hongrie
et puis je vous rappelle les trois
médailles d'or pour muriel hermine c'est
l'exploit français de ces championnats
d'europe
trois médailles pour muriel hermine
depuis une bonne nouvelle en hausse les
tice que j'ai appris que cariste on
irait aux roms vous écoutez stade 2 vous
avez raison à gérer le compte invité de
stade 2 en effet caristan a dit j'irai à
rome pour voir rome et courir il l'a
toujours mal mais il va beaucoup mieux
il a décidé de courir le 110 m haies aux
championnats du monde à rome
cyclisme tour de limousin jean marc
deschamps sait c'est surtout pour le oui
charlie madeleine victoire du français
charly mottet
c'était la dernière étape aujourd'hui
devant cornillet et gomez et puis en
images maintenant tennis boxe vélo et
foot avec pire trade and rage canada
toronto demi-finales femmes beau succès
de pam shriver deux petits sets et puis
s'en vont six cas qui feinte la tête de
série numéro 1 chris evert clubs
éliminés première victoire de pam
shriver sur sa compatriote en 18
rencontres
ça vaut bien une petite larme
dans le même temps à cincinnati boris
becker se débarrasse dans der j'arrive
j'arrive particulièrement énervé 6-3 6-3
baker jouera ce soir un autre suédois en
finale
hedberg connors l'ancien résiste bien
mais stephen le métronome l'emportent
pas mal tout de même qu'aux north ne
l'oublions pas à plus de 35 ans pour des
pays-bas laurent fignon enlève la 6e et
dernière étape mais trop tard c'est
l'enfant du pays toy vendent ligue qui
arrache la victoire finale accolades
embrassades ce numéro dit vous le
connaissez il y a encore trois semaines
il était parisien mal du pays les bars
qui retour à cologne pour sa première
rencontre
pierrot plante un but d'autres suivront
un coup sûr ko en série pour finir aux
jeux panaméricains costaud c'est cubain
il frappe fort très fort cinq médailles
d'or sur six qui dit mieux
manuel martinez félix avons roanne le
moose de très très beaux cogneur
impressionnant châteauroux via lors de
son festival un festival pas comme les
autres pas d'affichés mirobolantes pas
d'inflation de stars pas de venait-il
attendu simplement une autre conception
des choses
on vient à châteauroux non pas pour
consommer mais pour agir on danse on
joue de la musique on chante et les
meilleurs de chaque discipline sont là
pour conseiller pas pour éblouir
reportage jean-claude d'arrigo françois
landaise man
ils étaient 50 il ya 12 ans ils sont
aujourd'hui plus de 600 professionnels
et amateurs confondus à s'offrir au
festival de châteauroux un stage
intensif de rip de claquettes et de
chansons en fait toutes les disciplines
qui touche au music hall et à la danse
moderne c'est crevant bon à shanghai
acceptant repos c'est vrai qu'on fait
que savoir ce qu'on veut dans la vie
moi j'ai 45 ans je meurs conditions
bensalah
la plupart de mes élèves font cela pour
la plaisir aux joueurs deviendront
professionnels du moins je l'espère
l'âme du festival de châteauroux une
jeune femme nadia couleront ici en
répétition dans la nature avec un petit
groupe de danseuses en cours de
sélection parce qu'elle est convaincue
que le jazz sa passion à une place à
prendre chez nous dans l'expression
chorégraphique
elle a su s'entourer des meilleurs
professionnels anglo saxons pour elle le
festival qu'elle anime doit aller
beaucoup plus loin
en ce moment je suis à la recherche de
danseuses et de danseurs là y'avait pas
de danseur mais j'en cherche aussi pour
créer une compagnie de jazz dans
laquelle j'intégrerai peut-être des
claquettes et du chant donc je cherche
des gens qui la voient beaucoup de
cheveux de la participation des projets
et pas mal de transpiration le festival
de châteauroux commence à beaucoup faire
parler de lui
les pouvoirs publics et les sponsors
s'en sont aperçus qui aujourd'hui pense
très sérieusement que sont réunis ici
les éléments grâce auquel peut naître un
sens authentique de créations avec au
bout la comédie musicale à la française
il y avait un tir c'est aujourd'hui un
kart et le voici les résultats du tiercé
ils vont s'inscrire sur votre écran pour
gagner il fallait jouer le 18 le 3 et le
8 avec un rapport dans lord 5207 francs
pour 5 francs et dans un ordre différent
649 30 jours pour 5 francs et puis le
résultat du quarté + donc les mêmes
chiffres plus le 12 18 3 8 et 12 avec
rapport dans l'ordre 35600 29 francs 20
et dans un ordre différent 2300 francs
40 toujours pour 6 francs voilà un
nouveau sur cette antenne à 20 heures en
tout cas mais c'est un professionnel
reconnu dont vous connaissez la voix
bienvenue sur antenne 2 laurent cabrol
et d'abord des nouvelles des routes
oui de nouvelles hélas dramatique daniel
puisque depuis ans qu'est l'espace de
quelques heures pour ces retours de
vacances nous avons dû compter quelques
onze morts et 49 blessés sur les routes
de france qu'il s'agisse des routes midi
pyrénées ou alors de la région de
lorient ou encore dans l'aisne
de nombreux accidents donc à l'heure
actuelle la situation est relativement
calme sur les routes beaucoup de monde
dans la vallée du rhône beaucoup de
monde aux portes de paris si vous avez
des amis ou des parents qui sont sur
l'autoroute du sud n'ayez aucune
inquiétude il ya des travaux sur cette
autoroute c'est pourquoi ils sont en
retard certainement et alors quel temps
fera-t-il demain alors demain vient nous
allons passer nos corolle nuageuse au
dessus de notre tête chorale nuageuse et
fraîcheur brumeuse non touchés de
comprendre ce qui se passe en regardant
la photo satellite elle en dit plus long
que un grand discours puisque voyez ici
nous avons pratiquement pas
d'anticyclone l'anticyclone est
complètement dans l'air très très loin
de nous il est sur la russie et sur la
grèce
en revanche une dépression on la voit
très mal ici elle est ici la dépression
et l envoi sur nous et bien l'envoie
d'état de nuages beaucoup de paquets
nuageux que nous allons retrouver sur
notre carte la couleur du temps pour la
journée de demain avec tout de même de
belles éclaircies sur la façade
atlantique puisque nous aurons passé la
plupart de nos corolle nuageuse les
ondées se retrouveront sur le nord sur
le bassin parisien et sur la région du
centre les ondes et seulement en matinée
et puis attention aux orages y seront
violents dans les régions en particulier
sur les alpes du sud et sur la corse
mistral et tramontane dans le midi voilà
donc pour la couleur du ciel les
températures je vous disais son talent
la baisse par rapport à celle
d'aujourd'hui par rapport surtout à
celle d'hier des températures qui vont
18-18 match nul entre brest et cherbourg
23-23 match nul là bas entre mulhouse et
strasbourg
et sur la moitié sud entre 20 du côté de
limoges jusqu'à 29 degrés à bastia et
puis demain et bien le soleil ouvre à un
oeil à 6h56 il ouvre à il fermera ses
deux yeux à 20h49 pour la nuit de la
saint barthélemy puisque nous fêterons
les parts et lemmy la météo ce soir est
presque stable de deuxième voilà fans
cette édition merci de l'avoir suivi
prochain rendez-vous philippe harrouard
à 23h40 télé matin à 6h45 vous
retrouverez daniel bilalian demain à 20
heures
bonsoir
e